2023 saw many big events.
Some provided good news.
Most provided
bad news,
from democracies in decline,
to conflict and war,
to a climate in peril.
Here's a look back at the year that was
with an eye toward how these events
will shape the year to come.
Number Ten: Democracy is in retreat.
Democracy almost just
broke down in Guatemala.
Whether it is coups in Africa,
the militarization of politics
in Asia, or the assault
on the rule of law
in the Americas,
democratic institutions
are under attack,
imperiling liberty everywhere.
The fact that people
on the streets of Niger,
on the streets of Mali,
on the streets of Burkina Faso,
and now in Gabon, are welcoming
the military does not bode
well for democracy in Africa.
Number Nine: The space race heats up.
Space was once
the domain of the superpowers.
Today, the heavens are open to everyone.
Both countries and companies
are rushing into space,
fueling dreams of prosperity
and nightmares of great power conflict.
From a Space Force perspective,
we're in a little bit of a different spot
in that we are now contesting a domain
that just ten years earlier,
15 years earlier wasn't the case.
And so we're really trying
to build for a different what
on a different timeline.
Number Eight: India now has the most people
of any country in the world.
With a population of 1.428 billion people,
the South Asian nation is home
to nearly a fifth of humanity.
India's youthful population
is fueling a vibrant economy.
Meanwhile, China's
shrinking and aging population
are raising critical questions
about its economic
and political future.
The Chinese economy
is about to become a machine
for taking care of ancient parents and in-laws
and that's going to make for
big demands for social welfare
benefits for older people.
Demography isn't destiny,
but it's close.
Number Seven: Azerbaijan seizes Nagorno-Karabakh.
After years of unrest
and upheaval.
The war between Nagorno-Karabakh
and Azerbaijan is finally over.
Azerbaijan launched
a lightning offensive
against the Armenian
enclave in Nagorno-Karabakh.
The crushing Azerbaijani victory
ended a three-decade-old war
and triggered a mass exodus
from Nagorno-Karabakh to Armenia.
Over a hundred thousand
Armenians have fled
the enclave of Nagorno-Karabakh
since September.
And the question now is what happens to
those hundred thousand
living inside Armenia,
as well as the larger question
of whether a stable,
sustainable peace can be created
in this very volatile region.
Number Six: Civil war wracks Sudan.
A bid by a paramilitary force
to take power
from the ruling Sudanese military
plunged Africa's third largest country
into a horrific civil war.
Millions were displaced
as diplomatic efforts to arrange
a cease-fire went nowhere.
The conflict in Sudan
is an absolute horror show
for the Sudanese people.
Sudan's potential
disintegration here is incredibly
destabilizing for an already
really tough neighborhood.
Number Five: AI evolved
at a breathtaking speed in 2023.
Doctors hope AI
can help save lives.
Official intelligence
is being used to expand
the power of radiology.
Optimists hailed the advances
as opening a new era
of creativity and prosperity.
Pessimists warned that AI
was opening a Pandora's box
that would doom humanity.
It is becoming harder to define
what is human
because we are changing
what is human.
And AI
is going
to facilitate that faster than anything
any of us have ever experienced.
Number Four: U.S.-China tensions
continue to simmer.
Since President Nixon
visited China,
the bilateral relationship
right now is in its lowest point.
No doubt about that.
If China were to annex Taiwan,
the United States would find it
far more difficult
to defend its
allies in the region,
while China would gain
significant power projection.
A conflict with China
over Taiwan would be
catastrophically destructive.
The human costs are almost—
it’s impossible.
So making a deterrence
by denial strategy work,
preventing World War III is,
I think, the near term objective.
Hopes that China and the United States
would place guardrails around
their growing geopolitical rivalry
were dashed when a
Chinese spy balloon crossed
the United States in January.
A Biden-Xi meeting in November was polite,
but failed to yield any major breakthroughs.
The goal of the meeting
was to stabilize the relationship
heading into 2024,
when there'll be
elections in Taiwan
and of course
in the United States.
There were some modest progress
on issues like fentanyl
and establishing
military-to-military communications.
But perhaps the most important
outcome of the meeting
was that the meeting itself took place.
Number Three: Ukrainians hoped
that their summer counteroffensive
would break through Russian defenses.
But five months
of fighting produced
only meager territorial gains.
As winter set in,
the two countries
seemed locked
in a bloody war of attrition.
What Russia is trying to do
cannot succeed.
It's the wrong direction
for our world.
And they can't
redraw the lines on a map
or resettle
what international rules
based order is.
That's why Ukraine matters.
Number Two: A new Middle East war
dealt a profound
setback to efforts
to build a lasting peace
in the region.
Hamas's recent attack on Israel
is of unprecedented
scope and effectiveness.
Israel's devastating retaliation
degraded Hamas's
military capabilities,
but at a heavy price
for Palestinian civilians.
I think that it is going to be far
more devastating
and costly in human lives.
Palestinians want to live in peace
and freedom and dignity
alongside the state of Israel.
Just as troubling,
a wider war remains a possibility.
It's important to see the conflict
in Gaza
in the context
of the confrontation
between Iran and Israel.
Those two countries
have been engaged in
what's referred to as a shadow war
in recent years.
That's what makes a northern front,
including Iran's proxy Hezbollah,
well within the
realm of possibility.
Number One:
Climate change is no longer
a future threat,
but a current reality.
Global temperatures
continue to set new records.
A fierce
heatwave is gripping
parts of Europe, with temperatures
reaching more than 40
degrees Celsius.
Most of our area under
an air quality alert
because of smoke
blowing south
for more than one hundred wildfires
burning all the way in Quebec.
Even if you don't care
about climate change,
you have to realize
what's happening now
with the heatwaves, the wildfires, the flooding,
matters for our security.
Governments continue
to meet in solemn forums
that produce more pledges
than action.
Humanity may have missed
its chance to avoid
catastrophic climate change.
Carbon taxes are not a better idea
because they won't fly.
They’re just talk.
And we need to get past the talk
because my grandchild’s time is running out.